happy valentine's day snyder cup peeps
greg and john here how you doing john
i am wide awake and ready for trailers
called john what's like 10 times look
might have to do with that oh he called
me back all right looks like we're doing
it
together
we made it unite the league fun morning
been looking forward to this trailer for
a while
after we react to it we'll of course
talk about it go through some shots
especially after yesterday man oh boy
we did that bat take one can't tell you
how long i was complaining behind the
scenes of like
i don't get it why didn't i mention it i
knew it was from the dark knight returns
i had the thought why did i not let that
thought slip by while we were filming me
like we have no idea how long
i was complaining about not mentioning
it really there were hours
oh that was a nightmare yesterday
get it oh in the nightmare we're taking
too long
we never never take this long to get to
the trailer let's do it
already that music is so beautiful
legs
[Music]
he's coming back in black
we gotta look back at that steppenwolf
shot oh
warriors i'm building an alliance
damn straight
yeah i'm so glad the colors back is
[Laughter]
full circle baby
and a little mouse cyborg oh that was i
love that superman shot
that was great oh
god damn so beautiful so beautiful
what the hell i thought we see joker in
this trailer we live
[Music]
speak of the devils
that was the first time he ever said
batman i think so
is that the first time he's ever said
batman i've always said i've only seen
i've only seen suicide squad twice and i
can't recall the time he said batman i
don't think so
unless it's in that scene they added
back in under the overpass
and
oh that was such a beautiful trailer the
music is so gorgeous in it isn't it oh
yeah just the tone the gravity toss
let's see let's go through this a bit
his voice sounds so different
oh yeah we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
batman
it's a little more raspy it's a far cry
from all that chit-chat
yeah yeah he's much more and he's got
the swat vest on which i find
funny because at the end of suicide
squad and they broke out harley quinn he
was wearing the swat outfit
i'm pretty sure that's what it's in
reference it's gotta be in reference to
that we're taking it off
i'm gonna say this the reason not me the
reason not mentioning the bat tank upset
me is because i actually knew
that that was from dark knight returns
and that's why that upset me but there's
something i don't know please educate me
on
that is from the dream sequence that he
does have it's like a continuation of
the nightmare sequence yeah
and i love this shot because it's like
full
circle of superman it brings you back to
the beginning
of man of steel when he first got the
pseudo was first learning to fly
and then it also brings you back to bvs
when he died with the black coffin and
the rocks were rising
and now that he's resurrected he's black
seed superman it's like a full circle
story for
uh you know man of steel and how is it
henry steele
there's a different shot that wasn't in
bvs yeah but it's going back to that
moment when he died
uh when bbs had him and yeah the shock
waves were oh so beautiful
like haunting making that like it's
retroactively making bps that much even
better
yeah absolutely and then this is the
after effects of
bvs i'm assuming still continuing from
that moment which continues the theme
too because like bvs even does that with
man of steel
you know and then here's gotta be
themyscira uh
fallen over and then back to the
nightmare sequence of course
uh where we're going into the apocalypse
world man i
i love this i i love that granny
goodness isn't it yeah
that just makes me so happy that granny
goodness is very much a nod for
folks like you and as we're still alive
you should have got it at azer to play
her
there's no excuse zack snyder and then
you got here with darkseid with the
omega beams
on and then i wanted to see this shot
here okay
oh what a difference what a major
difference that is yeah
the steppenwolf injustice league whedon
version
looked like uh a weirdly done
dude it looked like a rubbery guy who
they should have just put in makeup
yeah yeah and this looks like a creature
and i like that about it yeah i just
love the details and the texture on his
skin like he just looks so
like battered and callous like he looks
icky like he wouldn't want to touch this
guy
yeah i just feel like roughy is even
just the neckline is the part that's
actually
grossing me out the worst here seems
like steppenwolf and this cut is good
it's gonna be gone yes he's gonna do the
jobs himself
damn look at this cyborg shot holy [ __ ]
that's a great shot dude
i'm definitely especially with all
that's going on i'm excited that this
trailer did not skimp on cyborg at least
not he's like the main focus but it
definitely seems like we're gonna get
some badass cyborg moments in this movie
i love the red is gone oh thank god
replaced with other actual colors then
we got this moment here alfred saying
how do you know your team's strong
enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bull don't wave your red cape at it
well he's going to go get a black cape
to wave at it now
what now outfit but dude the steppenwolf
in motion like just even this charging
shot looks so intimidating so much
better
yeah absolutely oh my god it's so much
better it just gives it this really epic
flavor that makes it seem a lot
more than saturday morning cartoons a
shot of paw cat so this must be super
uh him actually being resurrected yeah
you can see him being like lowered into
the liquid back there
yeah and then the drop i wonder if they
needed to get pockets
photos we need to get a precious memory
to bring back no
maybe yeah that could be it and this
must
okay this must be from the the sequence
it's having where
uh cyborg and the other trailers where
he's moving the warheads
semi dream secrets like he's imagining
his capabilities or
something like that i remember zack's
not talking about it in the live stream
saving iris
west looking upon her beautifully
not choking her putting her on the
ground without it
what is that i was like good on progress
character growth
no martian manhunter in here of course
what everyone's going to be talking
about
is that joker moment out of everything
here right
it's going to overshadow everybody
wherever we go all right guys well
that was a great ass trailer loved it
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button and last but not
least
david gandy david my dude
recently moved to arizona after
surviving
a stroke but he did mention to me
he started dating recently oh and i
won't go into too much detail it's his
personal life
david met said person and
part of their conversation struck up
because uh a photo with us
oh we are responsible for wingmen david
for your love life unite the league
and you get love that's right on set
valentine's day am i right david
we are the justice league of your heart
so really this is about how great we are
and how you owe us a patron of the day
shout out where's our shout out when you
are holding hands
it does your significant
you know a pause does not mean come on
in and talk god damn it
i'm sorry david
david